hey guys happy tech tuesday it's friday
pretty excited about today's episode
i've got a really fun unboxing of
nintendo amiibo
i kind of got a little excited already
opened one of them up because i wanted
to check them out i also already did
this unboxing with my buddy lamar wilson
so you probably already saw me unbox
these we had nintendo come to my house
and they showed us how to use these we
got all of these crazy in-depth smash
brothers tips if you're a beginner or a
professional at smash brothers check out
my gaming channel because in a few weeks
i'm going to release those videos
you know it's unnecessary a knife i
don't i actually do not need a knife for
this so i can't even fake it because i
don't want to hurt myself first one
we've got the villager who you may
recognize from animal crossing i was so
obsessed with animal crossing for a
really long time my real life was
suffering some of you guys probably
don't even know what these are so i
should probably explain before i
continue my unboxing these are amiibo
figures they're from nintendo they're
going to be sort of little additive
characters that you're able to level up
so you take this you place it onto your
wii gamepad it'll connect with the
gamepad with the wii and you're able to
start saving specific characteristics to
these characters so you'll be able to
play with this character in smash
brothers and mario kart and other
upcoming games they will carry with you
your gaming intelligence so if i were to
go to lamar's house and bring one of my
characters that i've leveled up in smash
brothers i'm able to play with that
character at his house on his game and
it will know how i play and help me
hopefully win since i'm not very good at
smash brothers currently i need to do a
little practicing my character probably
won't help me as much as it should next
we're gonna be opening samus
you look really nice you look really
pretty
you look beautiful girl love what you're
doing to your hair donkey kong
pikachu
sami the mario
marth
yoshi i love
i love yoshi so much what's really cool
too when you use these you can customize
each of the characters so when i was
playing smash brothers i made my yoshi
purple i named it whatever i wanted to
name it i named it ij
real original you can level them up you
can clear them and you can basically do
whatever you want
you got link focus
oh no she's my favorite the wii fit like
this is so cool she's such an iconic
character
of the wii fit community because i'm so
fit
oh man
so many random characters i love just
that's what i like about smash brothers
is they bring so many different
characters from so many different
nintendo realms
all together into one and you guys get
to fight each other
kirby
i think i'm actually gonna start
leveling up the wii fit girl anyway
thank you guys for watching let me know
which character you would play as if you
could choose any of these guys right
here who would you want to be and if
there's one that you would want to be
that's not actually here yet who would
that be i'm looking forward to playing
smack brothers hopefully i can play with
some of you guys i do plan on having
some smash brothers parties so
i'll see you there maybe it's a live
stream party i don't know now i've got a
big mess
to clean up
i'll see you guys on my next tech
tuesday let me know if there's something
really cool that you would like to see
me review on a tuesday it's not even
tuesday i'm sorry i've given up all hope
bye